please can you explain to me your most
emotional moment up-close with a killer
whale in your time as a trainer whether
it was Tilikum or one of the other
whales and what happened for me was the
time when the baby that I had been
working with for several years was
removed from her mother and it was an
incredibly emotional experience for me
watching the grief that she went through
in in that separation from her baby for
me I just the first time that I ever got
in the water with a killer whale was
just such a powerful experience for me
just being that close to an animal
that's about you know five or six
thousand pounds it's just an amazing
experience to have that connection with
with an animal where you know that there
that there's somebody home there and
there's it's like connecting with
another being but the sheer size of it
is just it just blows me away every time
so it was amazing
you